un grupo conservacionista tiene una meta
a largo plazo para preservar especies y
piensa que todas las especies en peligro
de extinción desaparecerán si se
construye en el terreno habitado por
dichas especies
el grupo tiene la oportunidad de comprar
parte del terreno donde se construirá
tiene la opción de crear una gran
reserva natural con un área de 45
kilómetros cuadrados y contener 70
especies en peligro o construir 5
reservas naturales cada una de 3
kilómetros cuadrados de área y con
capacidad para contener 16 especies en
peligro únicas en cada reserva qué
opciones recomendarías y por qué aquí
vemos algunos datos interesantes
recabados sobre algunas islas sus áreas
el número de especies en peligro en 1990
y las especies extintas en 2000 entonces
para las islas podemos ver sus áreas y
la proporción de especies extintas
estos datos se graficaron en un diagrama
de dispersión y debemos ser muy
cuidadosos al observar esto bien los
ejes el eje ya tiene la proporción de
especies extintas en 2000 es decir estos
números pero el eje horizontal no tiene
el área tal cual sino el logaritmo
natural del área porque hicieron esto
porque observen que cuando usamos el
logaritmo natural del área en el eje
horizontal en la gráfica parece que
tenemos una relación lineal pero tengan
presente que es una relación lineal
entre el logaritmo natural del área y la
proporción de especies extintas en 2000
pero la razón para hacer este tipo de
transformación es que ahora podemos usar
las herramientas que conocemos de
regresión lineal para analizar cuál es
la proporción de especies extintas en un
área de 45 kilómetros cuadrados en
comparación con las 5 reservas pequeñas
de tres kilómetros cuadrados pausa en el
vídeo y traten de responder a esto por
su cuenta
vean que nos dan los datos de regresión
para la recta que coincide con estos
datos resolvamos esto juntos hagamos un
poco de espacio y nos quedamos con la
gráfica ya que aquí están todos los
datos gráfica 2 y tenemos los datos de
la regresión conocemos la pendiente y la
ordenada al origen que es 0.28 1996 que
en la gráfica está más o menos
por aquí su pendiente es menos 0.05 mil
323 que se ve más o menos así esta es la
recta de regresión otra forma de pensar
en esto es que la regresión en general
nos dice que la proporción de especies
extintas es igual a la ordenada al
origen 0.28 1996 menos 0.05 mil 323 pero
aquí hay que tener cuidado porque
podemos vernos tentados a decir que esto
se multiplica por equis pero el eje
horizontal es el logaritmo natural del
área ahora podemos usar esta ecuación
para ambos escenarios para pensar en
cuál será la proporción de especies que
se espera se extingan en ambos
escenarios luego ver cuántas son las
especies que en realidad se extinguieron
y aquel escenario que tenga el menor
número de especies extintas podríamos
pensar que es el mejor o quizá el
escenario en donde se conservaron más
especies es el mejor veamos a ambos
escenarios el primero es el del área de
45 kilómetros cuadrados que es una sola
área cuál es la proporción esperada de
especies extintas
en esta regresión es 0.28 1996 - 0.05
mil 323 por el logaritmo natural de 45 y
si queremos conocer el número de
especies extintas entonces será igual a
la proporción multiplicada por el número
de especies en peligro que nos dicen es
70 sacamos la calculadora para encontrar
el resultado escribimos los datos y esta
es la proporción de especies que
esperamos se extingan en el área de 45
kilómetros cuadrados con base en la
regresión lineal
el resultado es casi el 9% y si queremos
conocer el número de especies extintas
sólo tenemos que multiplicar este valor
por el número de especies en peligro que
es 70 no sea aproximadamente 6.11
especies extintas vamos a escribirlo y
vamos a redondear esto para tener
números enteros tenemos aproximadamente
6 especies extintas y 64 salvadas ahora
analicemos el otro escenario donde
tenemos 5 reservas naturales pequeñas
así que tenemos 3 kilómetros cuadrados
5 áreas y hacemos lo mismo la proporción
de las especies que se espera se
extingan es igual a 0.28 mil 996 que es
la ordenada al origen de la recta de
regresión menos 0.05 1.323 aquí tenemos
el signo negativo porque la pendiente es
negativa por el logaritmo natural del
área que es 3 kilómetros cuadrados el
número de especies extintas es igual a
la proporción anterior multiplicada por
16 especies en riesgo por 5 áreas que
tenemos que es lo que nos dicen en el
enunciado 5 por 16 es 80 sacamos de
nuevo la calculadora para encontrar este
valor calculamos la proporción que es
más grande que la del escenario anterior
y ahora la multiplicamos por el número
de especies que es 80 para encontrar el
número de especies extintas el resultado
es aproximadamente
18.52 si redondeamos esto podemos decir
que aproximadamente se extinguen 19
especies y se salvan 61 y aunque
dijéramos que se extinguen 18.5 especies
y se salvan 60.5 es mejor el escenario
del área más grande pues tenemos menos
especies extintas y más especies
salvadas qué opción recomendamos y por
qué pues la del área de 45 kilómetros
cuadrados porque esperamos salvar más
especies y tener menos especies extintas
con base en esta regresión lineal nos
vemos en el siguiente vídeo